hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone this is
my red nose from the cold on battling
and you're watching Fandango indie movie
guide coming to this week from Savannah
Georgia this is a beautiful town a
little bit gothic and maybe a bit
haunted if you believe the ghost stories
so it's the perfect place to come to you
this Halloween but the reason I am here
is for the Savannah film festival this
is the 19th year of the film festival
and it's all created by the Savannah
College of Art and Design this year's
program has a lot of great movies that
I've seen other festivals but one that I
saw last night which I had seen was
Jackie this is a biopic of sorts of
Jackie Kennedy as she dealt with the
aftermath of her husband's assassination
it's a very talking movie I like the way
it was structured going back and forth
in time but really it all comes down to
Natalie Portman I'm going to put a big
awards watch over this one for Natalie
Portman's performance she is brilliant
she's so vulnerable and gorgeous and she
has the mannerisms down of Jackie O but
she just breathes life into that iconic
figure in this famous moment in time
there won't be another camera
there are two other Indies out this
weekend that are worth watching the
first is the documentary called gimme
danger we are in an undisclosed location
interrogating Jim Osterberg about the
Stooges the greatest rock and roll band
ever this is directed by Jim Jarmusch
and it follows Iggy Pop and the Stooges
this is a must for any music lover or
particularly if you love the Stooges and
even if you don't Iggy Pop himself is
just a fascinating character to what I
want to belong to the glam people
alternative people to any of it I don't
want to be a punk I just want to be
then there's little sister a drama about
a young nun who returns home and has to
deal with her dysfunctional family oh oh
you're home I recognize you with that
all the you know the Maryland mates and
stuff on your face everybody's talking
about your brother this whole phase huh
it's so fun seeing Allie Sheedy from the
breakfast club playing a mother to a
character who is similar to hers in that
role sweaters I am a disappointment to
you and you are a disappointment to me
this is a very sweet but unsentimental
movie and tells truths about family and
relationships and things that we all can
relate to and have to deal with and some
horror films i think you should watch
this halloween some recent indie horror
gems starting with the babadook you
continue winter it's in a look you can't
get rid of the babadook a rumbling sound
then three sharp knocks this is an
Australian film it features some very
freaky images and a lot of jump scares
but at its heart it's about a mother who
is battling with her own demons
then you should watch the witch the
Witch is a movie that almost defies
genres it's not quite a horror but it is
definitely very disturbing and creepy
it's set in 1630 New England about a
family who is dealing with a witch and a
very freaky goat and my third
recommendation if you haven't seen it
already is it follows you're not gonna
believe me and I need you to remember
what I'm saying this thing it's gonna
follow you
somebody gave it to me right past the
two this has been known as the STD
horror film it's about a sexually
transmitted demon the only way to get
rid of this demon is by having sex with
someone then you pass it on it's a very
interesting concept and shows how you
can do horror on a small budget with not
many characters and very few special
effects no it's me everything's okay
and that's all for this week's episode
of fandango indie movie guide coming to
you from the Savannah Film Festival it's
time for me to get in there and go see
another movie I'll catch you next week
bye